[Music]
hello good morning everyone and welcome
thank you for coming to our talk today
we're gonna talk about two very highly
requested user features which are new in
Android queue and that is dark theme and
gesture navigation my name is Nick
butcher I'm an engineer on the Android
developer relations team I'm my name is
Chris Bane's
and I'm also an engineer on the Android
developer relations team and I'm Rohan
I'm a p.m. on the Android system UI and
launcher team we've got a lot to cover
today so let's get started first up we
want to talk about dark theme wait
that's better dark team so why is that
keen important we think there's three
major reasons the first up is supporting
using your applications in darker
environments how often have you used
your phone in a darkened room and been
blinded by a bright white screen which
is not what you want supporting a dark
theme enables usage of your app in many
wider situations secondly we've seen by
lighting up less pixels on the screen
we've seen significant reductions in
power usage in fact in our tests we've
seen up to 60 percent reduction in power
usage when the app is in the foreground
which can be a real user benefit and
lastly dark themes can support
accessibility while maintaining
sufficient contrast ratios they have
less eye strain on the user so they
could be used by certain classes of user
much more comfortably so for those
reasons we've introduced a new system
setting in Android cue so now under the
devices display settings you can choose
between a light or a dark theme you can
also use a new quick settings toggle to
quickly flip between those modes and the
device will automatically kick into dark
theme when your device enters battery
saver now it's important to note that
dark theme is actually a system-wide
setting not just for the system UI but
it applies to all apps running on the
device and as such we think that users
are going to increasingly expect your
applications that you're writing to
respond when they set this system toggle
so here for example I've got two apps
running in split screen and when I
topple into a dark theme we can see that
only one of
responds and we think the users are
going to increasingly expect your
application to follow this now I've
picked on Google Drive here because
they're not currently supporting that
theme but all Google applications are
actually committed to update to support
dark theme by the time Android cue rolls
out so this is only going to increase
the user expectations so as such we
strongly recommend that you look at
supporting dark theme in your
applications now we recognize that's
going to be in some work for the
developers us developers and so that
search we're introducing something new
in Android q which is a feature called
forced dark now for stock attempts to
automatically and apply a dark theme to
a light themed application it does so
well let's take a look so here's the end
Google i/o application and here it is
with four starts being applied to it and
it just so in a kind of intelligent way
it runs at rendering time and it
actually inspects the views that it's
rendering and tries to smartly work out
which ones should be inverted in order
to run dark it even does some clever
stuff like looking at bitmap drawables
and tries to work out if there's a
variation in the hue is this some kind
of photographic data and not invert
certain kind of feel images so it's got
some smart heuristics in it for stock is
opt in you have to turn it on for your
application and you do so like this by
setting and for stock allowed to true
here I'm setting it at the team level
for my entire application for you so it
will apply everywhere throughout the app
but you can choose where to turn it on
so you could turn on just for one or two
activities and use it almost as a kind
of migration to help you rapidly adopt a
dark theme so for start can help you to
rapidly and atop dark theme but we still
actually recommend that you look into
designing a custom dark theme which you
can do so using themes and styles the
reason for this were there's two main
reasons for Israeli and the first one is
that for start is only available on
Android cubes so it's only going to
benefit users on key forward whereas
implementing a custom dark theme is
actually using the standard Android
styling techniques you can and roll out
your dot theme to all kind of major API
levels
the second reason why we think it's
important to go custom is it gives you
up most control over exactly how your
app renders which is what you want right
and you don't actually get to hook into
how forced are called dark in your
application so how it will change the
colors so if you want control over to
your designers want to be able to
control the exact shade of blue that
they fab here is gonna change to for
example then
a custom theme is the way to go so to
help you to design for dark themes we've
just released this week some updated
guidance on the material do website and
which covers how to generally design a
dark theme application and with specific
guidance around important areas such as
accessibility and guidance on how to
adapt your apps color system to work
under a dark palette in fact there's
another session at Google i/o right
after this one on stage one and which is
all about how to design the dark theme
so to implement a dark theme we
recommend that you take a look at the
app compat a material design components
libraries at which chris is going talk
about now thanks Mick so Dana is a
feature in app compat which we've had
for a number of years now which allows
you to easily implement one of those
custom themes in your app now what the
rate works is by enabling the night
resource qualifier and it works back to
API 14 which is Android 4.0 we've been
hard at work at the past couple of
months to improve it
and that is available in app compat 1.1
which is available now to implement a
fee muse and a night
you should the first we need to do is to
change your theme parent to be one of
the theme that I compact on day/night
variants if you're using materials on
components which I'd recommend you do it
also provides a day/night theme in its
version 1.1 again available now
as you mentioned earlier app compat
enables the - not resource qualified to
work and that is exactly how the phim is
implemented you can see in our default
configuration that day/night points a
theme that compact out light which means
that when the light seems selected we'll
use a light theme and where the nitin
when in our night configuration in
values that night it points to a themed
app compat which means it will go dark
the next we need to do is tell app
compat what motes use now we have two
api's for that the first is set default
light mode which is used when you want
to set a mode across your entire app so
all of your activities if you need a
local override in a specific activity we
have set local night mode now one thing
to note is that the values set on these
api's are not persisted so therefore you
need to set what you use the method
whenever your process brought up usually
I'll do this in your application object
using those API you need to give it a
mode and we offer four main modes the
first is mode light yes which means
always dark mode night no which is
always light follow system which will
follow the current system setting now on
cue because we have a new system setting
which is great it will do that basically
whenever the system city has changed
your app will follow it and when you run
on devices before cubes a PI or earlier
it will usually default to all white
theme the next new mode is called Auto
battery which you've added in app compat
1.1 and that is goes dark whether the
battery saver feature is enabled and it
works back to api 21 so here is it the
scene example where a device is going
into battery saving mode when that
happens or out or automatically go dark
when the user plugs the device back in
so it goes about to charge it and
therefore we leave battery saving mode
like so all automatic go lights again
the final thing to check is to make sure
that your activities are extended from
app compat activity
this may sound super obvious but it's
something which is easy forgotten
so as I said earlier we've been hard at
work over the past couple of months to
improve day night the day/night feature
and so I'd like to take you through some
of the things we've done so one key
change is that set default light mode
and that recreates any visible
activities it previously didn't do this
and you had to do all that work yourself
whereas we now do it for you we also
have an incompatibility with webview
whereas if you're using day/night and
then later inflated webview we'd reset
the theme and then things would go very
wrong and that's now fixed the final
thing is that Moton and mode my auto
time is not bet deprecated I said
earlier we've been hard at work over
fixing many many bug fixes which you've
all raised so hopefully if you've got
had any issues they're fixed that
follows on but at least into an app
theme setting so to support user
customization we recommend providing a
way for users to choose the feed that
they want in your app and an example
could be an e-book reader if the user
knows that they are always going to use
the app at night and they always want it
to be dark you want provide a way for
the user to select that we recommend
that even three options when we ran on
Android cue light dark and then system
default system default being the default
option for your app if you're running at
WAP been running on Android peel before
because we don't have that system
setting the options are slightly
different there now light dark and set
by battery saver
now the keen-eyed among you'll note is
that those options map free directly to
some the app compat modes and that's
totally on purpose there's a one-to-one
correlation between those options and
the modes we actually have and we offer
you so now going to hand over to next
talk about how elevation was to doffing
elevation so in material design and
elevation is a key concept for showing
the importance of some content in your
application and by changing the
elevation of the surface and for hinting
at interaction cues now in light themes
this is represented with a shadow and as
the elevation raises up the shadow
becomes more diffuse but when you have a
dark background like in dark theme this
can be harder to see and at search we're
introducing the idea of an elevation
overlays the idea here
that as the surface raises up to get
closer to the virtual light source the
actual surface color itself changes as
if there was a semi opaque white layer
on top of it which gets more opaque as
you raise up in elevation don't worry
we're not actually doing over draw over
the white layer on top this is actually
we kind of blend down the color and use
it as a tint on the background color so
to use an elevation overlays then all of
the components in material design
components version 1.1 onwards and will
support this at the Box these are the
components which use the color surface
attribute for the background color and
support elevation and as such just by
setting the elevation on the components
you'll get this surface overlay behavior
but if you want to build this behavior
into your own custom components and
there's a couple of options
firstly you could use the material shape
drawable which is the kind of background
drawable which powers a lot of materials
and shape theming as well as this
material and elevation overlays and you
can use these in your views as well it's
been augmented with new API such as
correct with elevation overlay and or
set elevation or set translation Z which
will give you this overlay behavior if
you can't use a material shape drawable
for some reason you can instead take a
look at the elevation overlay provider
class which is what material shape
drawable uses under the hood this gives
you a level method such as working out
the surface color for a given elevation
which you can then use in custom drawing
cing now implementing dark themes every
set comes down a lot to good hygiene
with your applications themes and styles
and we give you some specific tips and
gotchas and when implementing that loads
quite commonly and we've seen an issue
where applications which is designed
like this for a light n screen where
they might have dark text on a light
background when they apply a dark theme
and so that app see an issue like this
we end up with say dark text on a dark
background which you end up not being
able to read or perhaps the text
correctly inverts the light but your
background remains light so these are
common issues that we see in
applications and support in touch theme
and generally what this happens is
you've made some assumption that
somewhere in your in your layouts about
being running under a light theme and
you've kind of hard-coded some colors
like hard-coded Y
ground or black text in this case now
you probably not hard-coding things like
this in your layout but you're probably
using some kind of color resource and
this is essentially the same if you only
provide color value in the default
configuration this is essentially the
same that it's not going to respond when
running at a dark theme what you need to
do is provide an alternative color when
running under the nitric configuration
here in the values - night folder and as
such these colors will then respond to
the theme change better yet you can take
a look at using theme attributes femaie
tributes are essentially semantically
named colors and which have different
values when running under a light or a
dark theme so here for example I'm
changing the hard-coded background from
white to materials color surface color
which is a kind of background color and
so that will flip from white in a light
theme to a very dark grey when running
on a dark theme or likewise I'm using
the platform's text color primary here
for the text color which will give you
the inverse of that so it will be dark
in the light theme and light in the dark
theme in fact if you take a look at the
material color system it has lots of
these semantically named colors which is
super useful to be and for using in your
and designs so you're probably familiar
with things like color primarycolour
secondarycolour accents on and but
here's the surface color that we looked
at before and but they also provide a
series of on colors so if colors which
will contrast on top of their relevant
color so on primary one secondary on
surface so for example the on surface
color is a color which will always
contrast on top of that background
surface color so we can use this in
combination with a neat trick that color
state lists provide and to great effect
during dark meat dot themes so for
example here I'm using the fact that
color state list lets you separate out
the color from the Alpha Channel and
define them separately so I'm grabbing
the color on surface so something that
will always contrast the surface color
and applying an alpha modification to it
so this can be super useful if you want
to avoid having 50 different shades of
gray in your colors XML file but you're
scared to kind of update because you
don't know where they're going to use
instead of that if you can reference
these colors always guaranteed to be the
right color to contrast given a
different theme and just apply it an
alpha modification it can be super
useful one caveat is this Seban
kind of modification was introduced in
API 23 marshmallow so if you want to use
it beforehand make sure you're using the
app compat resources path or loading it
like this in code similarly whenever
you're loading colors in code using
contacts compact get color for example
and be wary that you want to ensure that
those colors as well have a knight
configurations or better yet you might
want to do something like this code here
which is querying the current theme for
a fee mattre butte so this is how you
can get access to something like text
color primary or color surface in your
code a no class of issues we've seen is
around drawables so if you have
drawables you'd probably want them to be
like showing up like these like troubles
here but you might encounter similar
issues as we saw before
well you might end up with dark on dark
why you could look at providing
completely separate versions of the
drawables under the drawable - night
configurations and a better way is
actually probably to look at tinting
because usually they're using like
monochrome icons that you just want them
to change the entire color of them so
you can tint it a couple of levels you
can either tint at the view level here
so here I am gonna tint whatever the
troubles give me with whatever color
secondary is for the current theme and
so will update it depending on the theme
or hopefully you're using vector
drawables and throughout your app your
and assets which natively support
tinting on the root element of the
vector so here I'm setting the color
control normal theme attribute which is
the standard and kind of gray icon color
so setting this means your icons will
always be the exactly right color or if
you're working in code you could also
use the drawable compact class which can
apply it in dynamically and to a
drawable as well and lastly it can be
handy to work out if you're running
under a current currently running under
a dark theme which you can do with some
code like this which actually looks at
the configurations UI mode and checks
whether and this is currently in night
mode so this is useful for querying
whether you're under night mode and
maybe branching your logic or setting a
different tint on a drawable some such
those were just some quick tips about
working with themes and styles we could
spend a whole talk talking about what
you could we're talking about themes and
styles and but we've actually already
done that a couple of times and so I
highly recommend you check out these
were resources on that and lastly I want
to revisit for Stark and talk about how
it can help you to migrate to a dark
theme
and so here's an application designed
for a light presentation and when we
apply for start to it we can see it's
generally done a pretty good job of it
like it's generally inverted a lot of
the colors but there's a few
opportunities it could be better in my
opinion in fact if we compare it to a
custom and dark theme which I designs
you can see a few things which for Stark
hasn't gotten quite right for example if
we zoom in on this draw ball on the Left
which is indicating the depth of a
threaded conversation for Stark has made
it a bit too light for my am taste what
you can do in these situations is you
can set and for stock allow to false on
any given view or view group and disable
the floor start behavior just for that
part of the hi Russ but remember when we
set for start to false the general
configuration is still running under the
night mode and as such we can use things
like tinting and this tint color will
give you the right color for a theme so
this will respond to the night
configuration so check out for start and
if you like I said it's one line change
in your and your theme to set for your
application or we've actually introduced
a new developer option where you can
force the entire device into this four
stop mode so if you want to check it out
now if you're running BT free on your
you can see how your app responds to
four stock it's a next up Chris I'm
gonna introduce some common scenarios
we've seen with dark made its Nick so
the first we're gonna talk about is web
content now the good news is that web
view works seamlessly with full stack so
if your opt into for stock when you're
running under a cue and you have an
example here so we have an app here
which is loading Google calm in a web
view and we've enabled full stock on
this app and when we go into night mode
it changes the web view content as well
it also works in Chrome Korean based
browsers and web view so soon actual web
content will be able to support dart for
you natively using the new CSS media
query cut the first color scheme we've
also ready dot theme support in custom
browser tabs and by that we mean the UI
around it so we have a new method on
custom tabs intent called set color
scheme it tastes one of these three
options now when here in light theme but
when we go to dark it looks a little bit
like this now you'll notice that the
content itself is
doesn't have force like applied or
anything like that that's because we're
aligned on the web content itself to use
that media crew we just spoke about now
map view itself doesn't support dark
theme out of the box but we can easily
make it do so by using its custom
styling functionality
now custom map styling allows you to
specify the colors and text and stuff of
a map leave a JSON file you can see a
link to a website we can actually
downloads and have stars that we provide
for you I mean there's nine stars on
their summer lights summer dark but you
can also customize it to your needs now
we can actually use that feature by
using the - tonight resource qualifier
that we spoke about earlier and to make
Matthew support daffy natively so in our
default configuration we'll put a light
styled map in the JSON file in res - raw
and then in res - raw data night we'll
put a dark style JSON file and that way
Matthew Roth massively load the rep the
correct map style and then use effect
colors
another issue we've seen when adopting
dark themes is with illustrations which
you're probably using in empty states or
maybe onboarding flows in your
applications if you just use the same
illustration design for a light theme
and under a dark theme you can see -
high contrast where these colors are
like way too saturated and they contrast
very highly on these dark and
backgrounds we recommend that you
provide an alternate version when
running under a dark theme which is more
harmonious with the kind of darker
backgrounds now you again you could just
provide an alternate version of this
draw wall so you have two versions of
very similar durables in your
application and but a better way to do
this might be to use an effective
drawables ability to reference color
resources and the individual fills or
strokes of paths and as such you can
vary just the colors and when running
under a night configuration so this way
you only have to ship one version of the
drawable but have the colors respond to
when it's running under a dark theme
next up is in notifications so
notifications in when running under a
dark theme should respond will respond
and go dark so if you're using any of
the notification templates these will
work just out of the box and but if
you're using a custom layout you're
setting a custom layout then all the
rules we talked about before about
sliding still apply so
assume it's running under a light mode
don't hard-code colors use fume
attributes in fact I'd encourage you if
you're and sliding any text in
particular to look at the subclasses of
the notification text appearance and so
your text will mirror that of the
system's notifications as well so that
was dart mode and our takeaways really
are that users are going to increasingly
inspect your expect your applications to
support dark theme so really really do
take a look and supporting it as well
and use app compat day/night and
material design components which have
lots of built-in support for n8
implementing this in your applications
and be sure to look for these latest
versions is one point one point knows
but because there's been lots of
improvements and bug fixes in them
consider four star as something to help
you rapidly adopt
a dark theme and maybe use it as a
migration tool so you can enable it for
certain activities and then roll out
custom themes and gradually and fee
match boot all the things don't think
about being hard-coded in a single
configuration a single color scheme and
be very flexible whenever you see you
know a hard-coded color or color
resource with only a single version see
that as a red flag so now I'm going to
hand over to Rohan who's going to tell
us all about gesture nap
all right so I have the benefit of
telling you all about gesture nap a few
of you might have played with it already
on beta 3 if you haven't make sure you
give it a go it's out there in settings
you can search for fully gestural
navigation but I'll do a quick refresher
of what it looks like right now in
Android cue so we're adding a new nav
mode if you haven't already heard in
Android to you that replaces the beloved
three buttons with three glorious
gestures and here's what they look like
on the left you can see that swipe up
from the bottom will become the gesture
for home swiping up and holding in the
middle will take you to your recent
and/or overview and on the left you can
see that swiping in from an edge will
take you back now the one thing that
this movie doesn't really do justice is
that we're also introducing swiping left
and swiping right in order to go back we
think it's a super awesome experience we
internally we love it we've heard really
great feedback we definitely want to
hear how you feel about it but
definitely give it a try so a big
question we've gotten is we're
introducing another nav mode in Android
you know what do we do like we're
developers what are you trying to do in
Android so I want to talk about that a
little bit really quickly in the future
for Android we're going to be supporting
two nav mode moving forward the first
one is three buttons you know Android
users love three buttons we know that
it's super usable and it also addresses
a lot of accessibility needs that
gestures just cannot on the other hand
we also know that there is a lot of
desire for gestures so we will be
supporting one gesture mode which is
what you saw moving forward in Android
and only that one I want to take a quick
step back and talk about why we're doing
this now before we dive into the details
for developers and talk about you know
user trends here so Dan Sandler talked
about this in his talk and what's new in
Android but users increasingly want
immersive experiences in Android and one
thing that device makers have done is
try to approach this from a software
side and what they've done is built
their own gesture nav and ever
every device maker has a different
impression of how gesture nav should
work what we recognized on the platform
side is that kind of gets insane for a
developer thinking about you know n
different gesture navs
when you're trying to develop you know
just design for tests for your app just
kind of gets insane so with that in mind
we introduced this gesture nav in queue
and we are going to be standardizing the
ecosystem as of queue on three buttons
and our model moving forward and just
just want to elaborate the problem here
you know there's a lot of different
gestures these are just some of them
dance talk had you know different swirl
gestures and you know maybe a knock
knock does something different but we do
want to unify that core set of gestures
back home and recents taking slightly
different spin on this why should you
care as an app I'm gonna regurgitate
that immersion bit but you know flipping
this a little bit there is an
opportunity for you as an app to delight
your user by bringing this immersive
experience to your app and making sure
that it's compatible with this new nav
mode in terms of compatibility we
recognize that there may be some
conflicts that you will need to handle
as an app and we'll talk about that
coming up cool so how do you make your
app nav ready and nav just means you
know any nav mode 3 button gesture nav
how do you prepare for this immersive
experience and more importantly how do
you prepare for gesture now there are
three things you need to do the first
one is making sure that your app goes
edge to edge which Chris will explain a
little bit more the second thing you
need to do is leverage and sets old and
sets and new ones that were adding to
make sure that any kind of critical
content is in a safe place and is an
optimal positioning and the third and
final thing is handling conflicts if you
do have a conflict how do you handle it
and how can you override certain
gestures so you can bring a better
delightful experience to your app cool
so I'll hand it over to Chris to talk
about that edge Thanks
yeah so what is actually edge to edge
well let's take a look at a typical path
when you're running on for cue today
so he can see the bounds of the app are
actually below the states bar and above
the navigation bar so what do you want
on cue I'll simply want the navigation
bar to disappear
allowing your apps content to be
displayed behind it to create a more
immersive experience when it Scrolls it
looks a bit a lot bit like this
so as recommendation drum behind the
navigation bar is now strongly
recommended on cue it's optional before
cue but one thing to know is that a lot
of the API is and how do you do this
actually works back to previous versions
of Android so if you're gonna put the
working for cue it's not that much more
work to do it for pretty cute as well
now let's take a look at that status bar
now similarly we actually want the
status bar to go away as well
again allowing your app content to be
displayed behind it creating a more
immersive experience and your heart
you'll hear the word and mercy of a lot
in this presentation so now our app was
a little bit light like this when he
Scrolls again drum on the status bar is
now recommended on cue an optional
before cue so we if we take a look at
our bounds they've come from here to
here which is where we get edge to edge
from so let's take a look at now about
how josh implement this stuff so the
good news is that from Android cue
onwards the system is now responsible
for recolor in the system buttons and
the handles so you see here an example
where as we scroll that navigation bar
handles bottom is changing color based
on the content behind it now the
recoloring can take the form of both
dynamic color adaption which you've just
seen or it could be static coloring on
less powerful devices when you've read
on all the platforms because there is
that recurring doesn't happen we
recommend that you set a translucent nav
bar color that's a the user can actually
see those buttons so to really make your
app go immersive there are three things
you need to do the first is change your
system bar colors second request to be
laid up fullscreen and then final thing
is to avoid any overlaps with your views
with the system UI let's go for it the
first one is to change the debate the
navigation bar color now we have this
attribute available in lollipop onwards
which we can use and we're just going to
say it's transparent when you run on
pile before you should use the
translucent color as we just mentioned
the next thing we need to do is request
to be laid out for screen now we're
going to use the infamous set system UI
visibility method with a number of flags
the two flags we need our flag layout
height and that tells the system to
layers out as if the navigation bar
wasn't there and a second is layout
stable which is a special flag that
tells it to lay us out at it at our most
extreme if you also want to be displayed
behind the status bar as an additional
flag you need to use called layout
fullscreen now when we lay that
fullscreen we don't want to have used to
be displayed behind the system bars and
that is where insects come into play now
insects are a collection of values used
to tell you how much to it move or inset
content by now what views you move how
much you move it by depends on the inset
and its purpose and you might have seen
them in window insects class there are a
number of types of insects the first
type are called system window insects
and they tell you where the system UI
has been displayed over your app they
are commonly used in reviews so they're
not obscured but any other system bars
so here you can see a fab at the bottom
right so we both at off blow that up a
little bit
typically a fab will have a 16 dip
margin applied to it and you can see
that they are denoted by these blue bars
so actually ingestion of it's not too
bad is only as good for the bottom two
dips or so but so we'll use the system
window inset to actually move that up
but in free button navigation mode is
actually a lot worse because the
navigation bar is taller that fab is a
lot more obscured so by using the system
winters we can move that up and make
sure the user can actually click it so
as a recap system window in sets are
used to move clickable views the next
type are called system gesture main sets
and they're new in cue now they
represent the areas in the window where
system gestures take priority visually
if they look a bit like this so let's go
through them
they include the vertical edges for the
back gesture so the user starts dragging
for when anywhere in the left and the
right hand zones the back gesture will
start triggering and again on the bottom
side where the home gestures takes place
again if the user starts dragging there
the home gesture will take will take
priority now as mentioned the system
window in sets will use for clickable
views system gesturing sets are used for
draggable views will go for an example
later the next and final type are called
mandatory system gesture in sets and
there are subsets of system gesture in
sets which define the areas which can
not be used with exclusion api's which
rome will talk about in a minute now in
cube they are currently only used for
the home gesture because that's a
protected gesture the user should always
be able to exit your app absent right
maybe not over the road so as a quick
overview sitting window exits clickable
gesturing sets of draggable and
mandatory system change gesturing sets
are used to check for the exclusion
api's actually have a difference there
we go
so the third and final thing in making
your app now ready is overriding system
gestures so Chris already talked a
little bit about some of those system
gesture in sets and ones that are
mandatory but I want to quickly talk
about what kinds of conflicts you may
have a handle and where you may need to
override so any sort of horizontally
draggable content that resides in those
back zones within those systems or in
sets is an area where your app may have
conflict I want to give a quick example
here but you know I opened up a photo
into the Photos app and I wanted to crop
a picture and crop my buddy out and
you'll realize that the crop handles the
little circles you can see on each
corner of that square are awfully close
to the edge and unfortunately those are
in the system gesture in sets and in
that back zone so there are other
examples like this you know with sliders
seek bars video seat bars for example
other drag handles etc that your app may
need to be aware of great so how do you
override some of these gestures how do
you make sure that you keep your user is
able to use those crop handles etc so
there is a new API available in queue
that will
allow you to opt-out of at least the
back gesture home is still a mandatory
area we know that's the only way a user
can leave your app so we're not making
that opt-out able but basically how the
API works is that you can specify a
rectangle on screen that where basically
you'll get touch events instead of the
system consuming it for back or for any
gesture in that area one quick word of
caution this is pretty powerful one
quick word of caution here is that be
really careful when using this users
expect to be able to go back it is one
of the most frequently used system
actions I think it's used twice as much
as a home and if you suddenly break that
and you know decide to take over the
entire edge for example your users might
get frustrated so be really careful when
using this and make sure that you have
very clear visual affordances such as
the drag handle that indicate that you
can actually swipe there and you know a
user will start interacting with app
content instead of going back taking a
quick look at the API it's going to be
in the view class and it's called set
system gesture exclusion Rex and it
takes in a list of rectangles where your
app will get the touch events first and
only you can use this an on layout if
you have kind of static content that
isn't really shifting or you can set
this in ondraw if you want more kind of
real-time frame-by-frame updates cool so
let's talk about some common scenarios
with all of these you know three pieces
of guidance and crystal take over here
right so the first in our we're gonna
look for is scrolling views now you can
see here content should be drawn behind
the navigation bar as the list Scrolls
but when the user reaches the end that
lists that final item should still be
above the navigation bar allowing the
user to interact with it
as you can see here when we reach the
end the list we still want those bottom
items lightning talks in this instance
still be above the navigation bar so
they use can interact so a common way to
achieve this would be free padding and
will pad a scroll and view using the
system window in sets that we spoke
about earlier
his quick code example we'll set an
unapplied window inserts listener and
then we'll wait some inserts and then
we'll just set the pattern on the
scrolling view and this is a recycler
view using the system window intercept
pardon the final thing we need to do
here is something called click to
padding now by default whenever a view
group sets padding or has padding set on
it it will clip its children
now that's be good because that's the
whole effect we want we want our
children to be displayed behind our
pattern read turn that feature off it's
a recycler view ListView and all the
other scroll and view support this so
I've just seen the set default the next
scenario is all about navigation drawers
now if you've tried betta free you'll
probably notice that a lot of options
navigation drawers and sometimes get a
bit funky so draw layout will
automatically exclude the correct edges
as necessary so he can see in the Google
i/o app that when the draw is closed it
will open and the next gesture when it's
open the back gesture will actually take
preference now to use this you need to
update to one dot one dot zero alpha one
which is released this week for bottom
sheets generally we want to avoid views
near vertical got the vertically
scrolling gesture zones but bottom
sheets rubs here a pattern which a lot
of apps use so for claps or bottom
sheets we want to make sure there's
enough content above the navigation bar
for the user to be able to actually drag
it so here we'll look an example where
we haven't done that and you can see
that as the user tries to drag the
bottom sheet actually the home gestures
gonna take take over and we don't want
that obviously so one way we can get
around it is y using the system
gesturing sets to increase our content
size allowing the allowing the enough
space for the user to actually drag it
so
since there's a code here we're using
the bottom sheet behavior from materials
on components and it provides peak
height so that's something that's the
amount of height available when it's
collapsed so here were just we again
were using on apply window incest
listener or grab-ass to some gestures
and then we'll just increase that peak
height now it's also about having view
calm path in the core library in Android
X and again we've released a new version
this week called it 1.2 alpha 1 but
remember users can always swipe to go
home + 12 not the bottom of screen so
even though we've done this and we've
moved the peak height up the users can
still accidentally trigger this gesture
and that's obviously annoying for users
so draggable content near the gesture
nav zone is possible but be careful if
you're going to do it one thing also to
say is that try and make the draggable
content will obvious the user so they
drag the right bear so he can see that
the actual header bar is fully opaque
the content below it is actually has an
alpha effect applied tryna guide the
user to the top section the next Mario
is carousels while that we mean view
pages or any horizontally scrolling
lists like recycle fuse now one thing we
don't really want is for apps asset
exclusion wrecks everywhere exactly a
problem for users if an app sex
exclusion recs are all across the left
and right zones the user is not going to
know where they can actually trick it
back and the final scenario is one that
landscape so if you've gone edge to edge
you know what we talked about earlier in
landscape when in button mode what we'll
actually get is this which obviously
isn't great so you can see that the
button options are actually obscured by
our apps content now this doesn't happen
on gesture mode it only happens on
button mode so if you have cut text
which starts near a vertical edge think
about padding all of the content in
horizontally I want you to know also is
make sure you test your apps both on
button modes and also the gesture nav
modes as a code example it's pretty easy
you just need to find a view somewhere
your activity near the top sit and on
apply' window it's an insert listener
and then set the left and right pad in
based on the system window in sets now
that's safe to use in all orientations
because it
always give you the right values and
once you've done that you're looking a
bit like this just want to say we are
adding more support in our Android X
libraries jetpack libraries to make this
a lot easier for you the examples we've
just gone through are just trying to
show you how we've tried to implement
this in our a lot in our libraries but
if you have custom views obviously
you're also going to need to do
something similar now if there's
difficult patterns that you're finding
please raise them and so we can try and
build better support for you via the
book tracker
there's a quick TLDR users will expect
that to work on all navigation mode so
please support it try and create most of
you eyes because it's giving you your
apps more real estate for to display in
perhaps if we update the jetpack and NBC
libraries because we are going to add
more support as time goes and only use
the gesture exclusion API if you really
need them they've really meant as an
escape hatch for your apps and finally
let us know about troublesome scenarios
the issue tracker we just worked out
thank you very much
[Music]
you